check this out ted cruz says biden's
comments on chauvin verdict are grounds
for a mistrial
he's right we saw it with uh maxine
waters she made these threats
over the weekend and the judge in the
case said
i'll give you this the defense
congresswoman waters statements
may give you something on appeal and
could overturn the entire trial
then we had joe biden come out today i
think it was today and he said
he was he was hoping for the right
verdict because the evidence was
overwhelming
now i don't know if that's ground
necessarily for a mistrial because the
jurors were already sequestered
but the idea that the the democrats were
making public statements
influencing absolutely yeah you got
these jurors man they know their house
is going to get burned to the ground
unless they give the
the extremists what they want so they
did
there it is that there's no justice
there's no fair trial here well and then
going back to the business stuff it's
the same way i mean
are they our business is going to be
boycotted then if you know
if they don't comply to a different
policy initiative or what
is going on in the in current events or
the political space
when i see people talk about censorship
and the weird can't like cancel culture
stuff
and they laugh about it yeah in a sense
where it's like they're not laughing
because they think it's funny what's
happening to people they laugh because
it's like it's just so absurd these
people are crazy
i'm like you realize that level of
social enforcement
where they're censoring speech they
don't like right where they're getting
people fired from jobs because they
spoke up or
stood you know stood up that's how
authoritarianism begins
you know i often say we in the context
of reading say 1984 or brave new world
or fairness
451 did everybody reading those just
assume
in those worlds one day blink there was
an authoritarian government
just like you wake up one day and
there's a guy in the screen saying i am
your dictator
no it happens gradually through social
acceptance
and social pressure the only reason the
government has power is because people
have confidence in it
so when you get to a point where
everyone's like i will either say
nothing
or i'll join the mob congratulations you
are you are on that roller coaster
heading right down into totalitarianism
yeah i i kind of actually feel quite
sympathetic for the jurors
people have people are saying like you
know they're pansies they're being
pushed around and i don't think that's
the case
i i i agree that they could be much
stronger but i also sympathize that
they're concerned about what's going to
happen to their homes
and their kids you know their families
but
tim seems to disagree i think about the
founding fathers
and i don't even know the number many of
the people who signed the declaration of
independence or their homes burned to
the ground yeah you're right
they were killed and there are people
right now
could you imagine like if like george
washington thomas jefferson
thomas paine benjamin franklin they're
like you know
chilling watching what's going on here
and they're like
you know a bunch of people died
for freedom for liberty for the
constitution for the bill of rights for
the right to
individual freedoms and now you got
people who won't even say words
there's you got people that won't even
risk losing money
there are people who literally watch
their homes get burned to the ground
because they believed in something and
today in america you have people who are
like
don't don't look at me i don't want to
be involved i'm not sticking my neck out
for anybody
so this is a point i made to catalina on
the drive back um i don't think that
we're going to be able to actually win
this war
or get our culture back without being
inconvenienced
we are in love with convenience we like
everything to be soft
and easy perfectly temperature
controlled we
have serious first world problems and it
is biting us in the butt
you know what i think you know i think
it is i'll say this was that in 17
you know in the 1760s up to 1780s enough
stuff with all the revolutionary war
there was no air conditioning yeah so
everybody was already drenched in sweat
and grime and all agitated
yeah so they were just ready for a fight
yeah it's like you're sitting there
you're in south carolina you're sweating
like crazy and then you get a letter and
you open it you're drenched in
sweat and it's like we are taxing your
crap
banging on the table now people are
sitting there in their massage
chairs watching nobody the new movie on
amazon prime with a deep dish pizza
overnighted from chicago to wherever
they are
and they're like i mean this is nice
it could be worse because it's not
impacting their lives but then you see
look what happened with robin hood and
gamestop and
uh even the the twitter censorship right
when it affects people's lives
personally i think that's when people
start kind of waking up
and wanting to have a voice and saying
that look i
this is not okay and uh you do need to
push back
but i think a big thing too is that like
our generation just really doesn't
uh i think our hit history of our
country
and the fact that you know in the 40s we
were fighting fascism we were fighting
nazis and even in vietnam right i mean
we have
our our country has been a beacon of
hope
and fighting the the real ideologies out
there and the real threat
of authoritarianism uh
decade after decade and yet and then
even
our founding in the fabric of how we we
came to be
america why is that being lost in
history why aren't millennials scared
to the core of communism and
socialism and then we're crazy because
we ca
we come out and we say this is
absolutely
this is absurd that we're even having
conversations like the green new deal
or even what's happening now with the
political unrest
well the the us fought the nazis like
you said
we we as a country we're engaged in war
and there was a very
uh atrocious uh political faction
and factions the axis powers and then we
had the cold war
yeah so we were constantly in this
ideological battle where we had to
protect ourselves
and then after the cold war or actually
with uh with nixon and some of the other
administrations coming up to the end of
the cold war i guess the us decided to
open up trade to china
maybe out of fear that if china went an
allied with russia more seriously then
we'd
have lost the cold war or something like
that now
the great ideological battle is the us
versus china but we don't have national
unity saying we must
fight and resist china the chinese
communist party now it's just
a bunch of billionaires saying stop
criticizing china
come on you know just buy our stuff one
yeah
that's a great point but i also think
about we were in you know the war on
terror for
20 years when europe not only in the
military or
even public opinion we look at when we
get into these conflicts
and it's like did we even have a goal i
mean why is this going on for 20 years
and now
we're going to talk about uh political
unrest
globally again i mean it's it's it's
almost
a lack of leadership uh and in different
administrations that i think have really
caused this and even congress
to a fault and just just the i don't
want to say
it's not complete incompetence but it's
definitely
agenda pushing from within that has
put us in this position now like with
china
i think we just don't have leaders yeah
i think that's the the big challenge
there are a few uh that i can easily
name in terms of conservative leadership
and it's people like steven crowder and
tucker carlson
yeah but they're not in politics right
if could you imagine if crowder was like
in the senate
yeah like he'd actually be doing things
right instead he's you know well he's
doing something maybe arguably more
important by being an influential voice
and i was we were talking about this
actually in the drive up it's just how
um everybody i think has kind of their
own gifts and their
their role in in civic duty in a sense
and i think journalists and
and people like tucker carlson and even
you guys i mean
they're such a everybody kind of has
their own way of kind of serving
right serving others and and serving
you know the fabric of our country in a
sense here within and
you know every again um i think
president trump
was a great leader i think in a lot of
ways he stood up and he was the fighter
that
a lot of people wanted and i think now a
lot of people are are craving that in
in at all levels locally and and they
just want somebody who's
not afraid to stand firm and stand up
and
fight for and be principled unlike the
republicans leadership now which are
like
just wagging the finger at maxine waters
but i will say
uh of trump he was absolutely
a fighter he was loud bombastic
tweeted like crazy but people accepted
that they finally had someone who was
fighting on their behalf so
what did the left say he was a strong
man he was a dictator
oh i'm sorry man donald trump being loud
bombastic and kind of erratic is better
than joe biden stumbling down the stairs
and being unable to negotiate with any
of these countries and just being weak
trump was far from perfect but at least
he was just over the threshold of
actually doing things and fighting for
things i think a problem is like i keep
thinking about eisenhower how he
basically acknowledged the military
industrial complex and they they
deferred leadership to this quiet
secretive organization that deep state
is somewhat running the government
running the world with military bases
establishing this liberal economic order
around the globe
yeah so a real leader would stand up and
say i'm going to break this apart
and get killed because they're they're
in the crosshairs they're vocally
speaking
they know where they work they work at
the white house
and they stand no chance they're
surrounded by people that are working
for that system the the
military-industrial complex it's
so a real leader it's almost like you
don't see them like
but we want someone to step up and speak
and we want that person to be the leader
at least i do
it's inspiring but in modern days when
the leaders are be
in the shadows and i use the word leader
in in an odd way the people that are
making the decisions yeah
maybe aren't this maybe that's the
leadership
system oh and that's the same thing
about with eisenhower it's like he was
on the ground with his troops right you
read every type of servant leadership or
leadership book whether it's business or
military
the best leaders are there on the ground
with their people and the issue
especially now when you bring up the
establishment to kind of like
tie everything together we were talking
about earlier is that
these people sit in their ivory tower
and they're in dc
you have these bureaucrats you have
these people that are in a far away
place as reagan used to say
and they're not in tune with the
everyday american
they're not in tune with what people
want and and what
where the country is going why are our
manufacturing companies are getting
shipped off to china
because our politicians don't understand
small business owners and they don't
understand
how their policies are affecting
everyday people in everyday lives
and i think that's the biggest issue we
don't have enough people on the ground
yeah i would love to see a president or
like a leader
get on like a video chat conference with
30 other people and just and listen to
them all
right for like two or three hours a day
right
well the the the two big issues that i
see
one economics obviously under donald
trump yeah the economy did really well
in 2019 it was kind of a crazy year just
everything was going so great for so
many people
and then covet happened which then
everything kind of went really bad for a
lot of people but under trump the
economy
when things were not you know coping but
you also had the critical race theory
stuff which is now becoming more and
more pervasive
donald trump signed those executive
orders i don't think he understood the
problem enough but he still took action
and now you have joe biden basically
going as woke as possible
rescinding his executive orders and now
it's gonna start getting uh
it's gonna start getting really really
bad i mean these people are overtly
racist
and the the policies that they push are
incredibly divisive
so i have to wonder because we've had
this conversation with china uncensored
i think and james lindsay actually
where you know what is china doing in
terms of the wokeness
and and the culture war and it may be
that they're exacerbating it
they're trying to so while they're
extracting our manufacturing base
in our and in our economy they're also
helping to seed
an extremely divisive and racist uh
ideology which
in my opinion is antithetical to the the
constitution
and you know what americans believe but
that is becoming more more pervasive
you get someone like joe biden you get
someone like kamala harris and that's
and that's it it's gonna start spreading
it's gonna get worse
and then we're going to see more and
more democrats that are embracing this
stuff
you start seeing even some republicans
you know
start to dance around this kind of stuff
and then eventually you'll have a bunch
of weird cult dogma ideology
which as far as i'm concerned may as
well be a religion and it's going to be
infecting government
and we were talking where's flo state
yesterday you ever do meditation
absolutely love meditation this this
this racism and this this weird ideology
that you're talking about it's like it's
infected the mind and it's making people
think on overload and overload maybe
it's not making it but it's that's what
they're
so when you can clear your mind that's
the way out
i think i think people are
what's the right way to put it they i
think deep down many people know
it's an it's an inherently evil and just
like corrupt ideology
but they know that if they speak up
they'll be canceled they'll be
threatened so it's like the jurors
you know what i mean they they're like
i'm not going to say anything cause i
don't want my house burned down
there's a lot of people who are like i'm
not going to challenge the the woke
you know establishment and this critical
race theory stuff because it'll destroy
my life in my career
but then you look at someone like you i
mean you you talk about it almost every
day
and and complain about it and your
career is thriving so and that's why i
keep telling people to start doing it to
start standing up
because it's it's it's it's i don't i
don't know exactly where the quote come
from comes from i will tell you that i
i think i accidentally made up a quote
from andrew breitbart
where someone told me this they said i
was told that breitbart said this and he
didn't but it was
you walk towards the fire and it's scary
at first but on the other side is
freedom
and so you have all these people who are
seeing this fire and they're like i
can't do it i can't it's bad
and then i'm like watch and i run and i
jump jump over the fire jump through the
wall and you're fine
jump right through no problem and
there's freedom the other side we're all
hanging out we're all we're all free
no no one can do anything to us they
can't take anything away from us
we've built something new that is ours
but you have to keep moving when you get
close to that fire because if you stop
when you burn and you panic you're gonna
burn to death and but
is it does it all come down to and
almost to bring in the meditation aspect
as well
and like the self and the ego and all
that is it
a courage issue right and like a lot of
people you know
our country was founded upon individual
liberty personal responsibility to
to take risks to be whoever you want to
be there's no ceiling
you know you define who you are you
define your own destiny
but then we've slowly eroded into no you
must comply
you are in this social order you are you
know even with the school system
you know you kind of have to fit this
mold and are are we as a society
just so um have we just been so
kind of led onto this
kind of social structure this is the way
things are supposed to be therefore we
we shouldn't speak out we shouldn't have
the courage to speak out and then it
goes back to kind of like meditation
is that are we all just striving to kind
of unlock that courage and
unlock that that self and get rid of
that ego and stand firm and kind of move
forward and i think
more people need to do that yeah sure i
was growing up in public school system i
was always afraid to speak out
hand up yeah i didn't want to get in
trouble that was a big part but i don't
want to get in trouble
and taking psychedelics opened my mind
and made me realize how powerful i am as
an individual
uh especially marijuana was the first
one psilocybin
and the government has made those
substances illegal for a reason it's not
a weird coincidence like those are
powerful
individual creationism tactics to use
chemicals
in life and
it it's very dangerous for the natural
order
to to constantly have upheaval so i
understand why
why they're they're controlled in a way
but
to our detriment as we can see a
psilocybin was just made legal in dc
like and
used for ptsd and i'm sorry you said
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you